on découvre que son plus grand ennemi
politique finalement contrairement à
tout ce qu'on a pu penser c'était
clairfeld
bonsoir c'est vrai qu'à la fin de
s'allume c'est très copain avec François
Mitterrand je sais pas si c'est le mot
mais enfin
disons qu'on dit ça oui
et aujourd'hui c'est plutôt ça
vous publiez ces plans un livre qui
s'appelle jeune homme vous ne savez pas
de quoi vous parlez c'est comment on
fait Georges Marc je ne fais pas pour
moi si si on le fait pour soi d'habitude
non mais je vous le dis
vous faites les autres le font par
politesse
alors quand vous lisez le rapport
Gabriel de Jean d'Ormesson ou François
Mitterrand parle la gendarmes sont du
lobby juif
vous vous savez que c'est vrai puisqu'il
vous l'avait dit il a employé ce mot-là
je le raconte dans ce livre dans une
conversation qui situe environ 15 jours
avant la condensation avec avec Jean
d'Ormesson mais je suis pas d'accord
avec l'interprétation qui en a été faite
on peut pas en conclure que Mitterrand
était antisémite
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
bah oui le titre jeune homme vous ne
savez pas de quoi vous parlez fait
référence à un repas au restaurant La
Marée à Paris dans le 17e vous êtes avec
François Mitterrand Daniel Mitterrand
qui a d'autres
personnes que j'ai pas envie de citer
bien alors à une table à côté il y a pas
bon Maurice Papon donc qui ne dit pas
avec nous qui ne dit pas avec vous vous
dites comme ça vous vous apercevez pas
pont au fond de la salle et vous dites
et dire que ce Dinan ville pas de
réponse de Mitterrand pas de réponse de
sa femme et dire que il a mis le même
zèle à mettre des déportés dans des
trains à Bordeaux que pour faire jeter
des Algériens dans la Seine en 61 c'est
vrai silence bien sûr c'est vrai silence
vous rajoutez heureusement qu'il sera
bientôt jugé et là Daniel Mitterrand
évidemment elle se coupe un peu elle a
un peu nave elle dit à devant vous elle
dit à Mitterrand mais Papon il était
très sympa avec toi du temps de
l'Observatoire donc lui il a fusil du
regard évidemment parce que
il dit quand même elle est gaffeuse
maman
et là ils se retourne vers vous avec un
air terrible et il vous dit vous ne
savez pas de quoi vous parlez jeune
homme et donc comme vous le racontez
avec beaucoup de mépris vous dit ça
la mitraille commence
et qu'est-ce qui vous dit
il dit ce qu'il a longtemps souvent
répété 50 ans après on ne peut pas
comprendre 50 ans après on ne peut pas
tirer un vieillard de son lit c'est ce
qu'il disait en cette scène et aller le
traîner en justice si ça réticence à
vouloir ouvrir les placards de
l'histoire il dit bon on a fait
l'épuration elle a été bien faite elle a
été trop faite elle a été mal faite ne
réouvrons pas les plaies du passé alors
ça peut être une position de chef d'État
est-ce que c'est la position de notre
génération je ne crois pas mais
finalement tout le monde a dit ça et le
général de Gaulle le premier de Gaulle
il a laissé papa en place puis en 61
quand il jette des Arabes dans la Seine
par définition c'était de Gaulle le
président de la République oui enfin
c'est plus compliqué il le laisse en
place à la Libération d'ailleurs
indiscutablement parce que finalement de
Gaulle préféré avoir des bons préfet ou
sous préfet vichiste que des communistes
ou des résistants aux commandes ils
étaient trop dangereux on les expédiera
en Indochine d'ailleurs cela donc on
laisse en place la France de Vichy
contrairement à ce qu'on pense en fusil
quelques stars on emprisonne Guitry etc
mais l'essentiel des élites qui a été à
Vichy et c'est pour pour ça que le
procès fait la mi-temps est assez
injuste parce qu'il est il est parmi
d'autres et c'est au moins mal tenu que
les autres mais l'essentiel de la France
était à Vichy c'est ce que j'appelle
l'Atlantide dans mon livre formidable
concept on va y venir alors je veux
rester sur ce dîner parce qu'à la fin de
de ce dîner quand pas pense en va du
restaurant il fait un signe discret à
Mitterrand et c'est ça qui vous a là
vous comprenez d'un seul coup la
connivence qui est entre ces anciens de
Vichy d'une certaine façon
il y a un monde où il c'est le concept
de l'Atlantide il y a un monde disparu à
Vichy le 10 juillet 40 se précipite
toute la France les administrations ce
qu'il en reste l'Inspection des finances
l'Inspection des finances on parle
aujourd'hui des inspecteurs des finances
mais la vraie naissance au pouvoir de
l'Inspection des finances et Vichy la
préfectorale l'armée en fait tout ça a
été à Vichy alors à partir à l'intérieur
de Vichy avait des familles le concept
de Mitterrand et qui l'emploi à cette
expression qu'il emploie pour la
première fois lors de ce dîner il y
avait deux catégories à Vichy il est mal
embarqué bien arrivé Mitterrand était
disait-il un mal embarqué bien arrivé
dans un accent de vérité bien arrivé en
43 et puis les mal embarqués mal arrivée
cela avait été peut-être au moins malin
ou moins Moreau ou moins courageux mais
finalement c'est la bourgeoisie qui
sauvent qui sauvent les meubles quoi les
soudards de la collaboration ils vont
crever c'est c'est assez singulier
dans votre concept d'Atlantide c'est
formidable merci non mais c'est vrai
parce que c'est exactement ça et
Mitterrand vous le découvrez le seul
coup comme la figure centrale d'un d'un
réseau d'anciens vichistes auquel il
rend des services non non il faut être
précis c'est pas la figure centrale d'un
réseau d'anciens vichistes il y a une
souche politique qui est à Vichy et qui
est un antigolisme de droite il y a des
relations qui se noient à Vichy car
c'est un être un jeune homme très lancé
finalement très séduisant et beaucoup de
gens se raccrochent à lui lui se crée
des liens mais il est pas et
après-guerre il recycle un certain
nombre de Vichy il est pas le réseau
central il refuse d'ailleurs assez
courageusement
parce qu'il pourrait rentrer dans le
gaullisme comme Chaban-Delmas ou comme
coupe de Murville et finalement se
blanchir il décide de faire sa vie sans
de Gaulle alors dans son cabinet il y a
des anciens wishlist mais il y a aussi
Georges Dayan et des résistants donc
tout ça est un milieu de Quatrième
République très complexe par rapport aux
autres membres aux autres Atlantes
puisque ils avaient l'Atlantide ils
visitent les prisons il leur trouve du
boulot il les aide à gagner des procès
c'est ce fameux rendez-vous le premier
rendez-vous avec de Gaulle toute sa vie
il a raconté dans sa se passe en
décembre 1943 le jeune Mitterrand arrive
par des circuits d'avion absolument
impossibles et il est face à de Gaulle
et toute sa vie il a raconté de Gaulle a
été très antipathique ça c'est très mal
passé il y avait de l'électricité dans
l'air il a voulu me faire tuer après etc
et tout ça finalement je le découvre
avec dans une conversation avec colonel
Passy un certain nombre d'historiens en
atteste il a beaucoup pour enjolive il
en a fait le socle de sa légende rebelle
à 27 ans contre de Gaulle en fait je
crois qu'il y a une vraie humiliation
avec le rendez-vous c'est pas mal passé
mais qui Mitterrand comme on dit n'a pas
été calculé par De Gaulle et je crois
qu'il y a ça ça a eu la manière dont les
gaullistes ont de parler de Mitterrand
ce mot c'est mitrant cette manière
négligence d'écraser le mot et ben oui
il a dû l'appeler mitrant il a dû être
humilié jusqu'à ce que vous en parliez
tous les tous les dieux amels les
Giesbert les Catherine nés
pas d'une opposition française qui était
fondatrice
et je leur je le rappelle mais c'est ce
qu'il nous a tous raconté pendant des
années et c'est vrai qu'à un moment de
sa vie il me dit vous savez ça c'est pas
si mal passé le rendez-vous avec ce qui
se mettait en paix avec sa conscience
est-ce qu'il rectifie encore un peu
d'histoire avec les pieds parce que la
date la durée le fait qu'il y ait freiné
ou pas freiné enfin il a ça a beaucoup
varié cette histoire il dit on a
rencontré ce que vous dites on a raconté
des bêtises sur cette rencontre parce
que plus étonnant dans votre bouquin
quand même c'est quand il parle de Vichy
il fait avis alors à Pétain c'était un
vieillard un peu dépassé mais magnifique
Mitterrand
quand il a déposé il a persistait à
déposer cette gerbe sur la tombe de
Pétain en 92 j'ai eu cette conversation
avec lui
Verdun c'est le plus grand traumatisme
de l'histoire française avec la Shoah
est-il un million 300000 morts c'est ça
laisse des traces dans le pays je lui
dis mais le Pétain de 40 au glitter le
Pétain de Verdun qui est considérable et
je crois qu'il fait partie d'une
génération c'est ça notre divergence où
il pensait que Verdun c'était aussi
important
que 40 il était sur la ligne que décrit
Henry amour ou 40 millions de pétanistes
c'est très curieux c'est très curieux
paix en raconte sa fascination de jeune
homme quand il le voit pour la première
fois au casino de Vichy comme ça il y a
des lettres exaltées et je crois que
quand on est vieux
c'était un vieil homme des les souvenirs
du cortex jeune à la surface mais
probablement mais c'était pas la
fidélité idéologique je pense qu'il
était pas c'est plus sentimental qui est
logique que vous pensez sa jeunesse sa
bohème les épaules de Daniel Darrieux
qui découvrent au bord de l'Allier
la bambou là et puis il a découvert du
monde il sort du stade et tout toute la
France toute la France et là sur un
kilomètre carré
il parle de Bousquet enfin vous parler
de Bousquet donc
Mitterrand regrette que la carrière de
Bousquet était brisée à l'âge de 35 ans
il regrette la façon dont Bousquet était
abattu par Christian Didier
on découvre que son plus grand ennemi
politique finalement contrairement à
tout ce qu'on a pu penser c'était
clairfelda j'ai rencontré en faisant
slip j'ai essayé de reconstituer ce qui
s'était passé pour moi et c'est
finalement la trame de ce livre il y a
une guerre de la mémoire elle commence
le 16 juillet 1992 au monument du Val
d'IB c'est le 50e anniversaire de la RAF
des Juifs de Paris Mitterrand vient
c'est la première fois qu'un président
français vient c'est un événement énorme
et il est hué pas d'interpose dans un
assez beau discours que certains ont pu
contester et là je crois que c'est le
premier choc c'est une manif voulue en
partie par Serge klars Felter un
objectif politique qui est finalement de
faire reconnaître les responsabilités
françaises dans le loco s'il l'écrit il
l'a dit dans 78
bien c'est que claire'sfel connaissait
le passé un peu maréchaliste disant de
Mitterrand et qui comme une épée de
Damoclès pour lui faire accepter
certaines choses le père de clairefel
était dans un réseau d'ailleurs assez
proche de celui de Mitterrand et quand
quand Mitterrand fleurit la tombe de
Pétain à l'île d'yeux ce que faisait
tous les présidents de la République
tout le monde l'avait fait tout le monde
l'avait fait en face le De Gaulle la
réinstituer en 67 parce que c'est le
cinquième anniversaire de Verdun
Pompidou a fait une fois ou deux Giscard
une fois ou deux Mitterrand a été disons
plus assidu malheureusement alors que
fait clarsfel il oblige Mitterrand sous
la pression parce qu'il a il a des
dossiers d'une certaine façon à faire la
journée commémorative de la rafle du
Vél' d'hive le 16 juillet ça se passe
pas tout à fait comme ça Mitterrand
s’obstine et il puisque klarsfel me
menace bien sûr je vais plus mettre de
de gerbe sur la tombe de Pétain je la
mettrai sur toutes les tombes de tous
les maréchaux de 14-18
et finalement la maladresse de
Mitterrand fait que la crise étale qu'il
effectivement accède à la demande à la
première demande de cercle cette journée
de commémoration du 16 juillet tout
tourne autour du 16 juillet parce que la
guerre de la mémoire elle se finit le 16
juillet 1995 trois ans plus tard et là
c'est Chirac qui est président et il
fait le discours que Claire's Feld
attendait que Mitterrand n'a pas voulu
pendant ces trois ans il y a une vraie
guerre entre Mitterrand d'une part une
partie des responsables de la communauté
juive des intellectuels
qui est intéressant c'est ça la phrase
jeune homme vous ne savez pas ce que
vous parlez c'est finalement la guerre
de deux générations la guerre de 2 de
morale et c'est ça que j'ai observé
d'ailleurs sans vouloir faire de
jugement de valeur parce que tout ça est
très complexe mais pourquoi il a pas
accepté de reconnaître la culpabilité de
la France dans Vichy
il l'a fait
la position il avait une position
gaulliste puisque de Gaulle a toujours
dit la France était pas affiché était à
Londres
donc il avait une position quelques
petits pas en fait je crois que les gens
de cette génération étaient très
emmerdés on peut pas ils ont essayé et
tout le monde a essayé de cacher ce qui
s'était passé pendant 40 ans on en parle
beaucoup beaucoup depuis 10 ans mais
pendant 40 ans on a pas parlé
effectivement la chape de plomberie et
effectivement il faut aussi ne pas
tomber dans le piège dans lequel tombent
parfois Serge clochfeld que par ailleurs
je respecte qui est de dire les
responsabilités de la France et les
mêmes que celle de l'Allemagne le
français allemand tous tous des
porteurs il faut dire c'est que la
France avait perdu la guerre George Marc
la différence quand même ce qu'il faut
toujours bien rappeler c'est que la
France avait été envahie par l'Allemagne
on s'est toujours plus difficile quand
on est envahi par un pays plus fort que
soi de faire ce qu'on veut un double
malentendu entre disons la France de
Mitterrand et la communauté juive
pendant 40 ans on a on a nié on n'a pas
parlé de l'Holocauste on a caché on a
caché le responsabilité de la police on
a caché les responsabilités
administratives on a caché tout ça et
d'une certaine manière il y a une vraie
blessure dans la communauté juive il
faut dire que la nation elle a été
amputée d'une partie de son ses membres
et ça la France ne l'a pas accepté ce
qui fait le chagrin des Juifs et je
crois aussi qu'il y a un autre chagrin
qui est le chagrin de la France qui est
que l'empire la deuxième puissance
mondiale s'est effondrée comme un
château de Cannes de manière
inimaginable en huit semaines deux mois
entre le 10 mai le jour de l'offensive
allemande et le 10 juillet ou la
République est aboli en deux mois la
deuxième puissance mondiale s'effondre
dans la honte avec des ministres qui
partent en pleine nuit oubliant leur
dossier la panique généralisée et que ce
traumatisme là s'est effondrement là de
la France puis d'ailleurs ensuite la
guerre d'Algérie savent ça a été en tout
cas cet effondrement une blessure
terrible aussi pour la France qui a qui
a rendu possible le vichy level 10 et
toutes ces saloperies et donc ça aussi
cette blessure là Mitterrand l'avait il
y a une forme d'orgueil à ne pas
l'avouer vieil homme George Marc pour en
finir sur le bouquin et pas le coaction
le lobby juif il l'entendait comment
Mitterrand quand il vous disait ça c'est
clairfeld c'est clair c'est clair
sa petite ce petit association très
vaillante de fils et fils déportés je
crois que ce mot finalement était
introduit par quelqu'un de son entourage
qui a fait une mauvaise action non pas
que je sois puritain mais ça on fantasme
toujours quand on dit le bijoux en
l'occurrence c'est clairfeld et puis un
certain nombre de gens motivés mais
finalement la question de Vichy comme la
question de la guerre d'Algérie comme
tout ça c'est le problème de la France
bien George Marc a eu beaucoup de
réactions à votre livre et dans le point
la semaine dernière il y avait les
bonnes pages de de votre livre dans le
point de cette semaine il y a une lettre
ouverte des amis de François Mitterrand
qui disent le principal reproche qu'on
peut faire à François Mitterrand c'est
d'avoir accueilli des gens comme George
Marc Benhamou auprès de lui
je veux rectifier la plancha la pétition
Charras oui c'est la pétition Charras
c'est pas les amis français amis
journaliste j'ai jamais été conseillé
spécial ministre du Budget
médecin je suis un individu oui ce
qu'ils disent dans leur pétitions
le texte était prêt avant que le livre
soit imprimé donc personne ne l'a lu
monsieur la semaine dernière ils ont
peut-être lu des extraits ils ont lu les
bonnes pages 3% du livre et d'un livre
complexe c'est d'un livre un briquet
d'un livre que j'ai mis des années à
écrire ils ne l'ont pas lu et Monsieur
charade dit partout d'ailleurs je ne
lirai pas ce livre mais c'est un torchon
vous pensez pas que le fait de faire un
livre ou Mitterrand reparle du lobby
juif ça peut réveiller l'antisémitisme
en France non parce que je crois que
j'ai fait un livre au contraire très
nuancé pour expliquer qu'il y avait qui
a eu entre 1992 et 1995 une guerre de la
mémoire entre et un vrai débat de haut
niveau parfois parfois tortueux et je
pense que j'ai voulu montrer une
complexité française la France ça n'est
pas que le mal la France n'est pas que
le bien que nous disait de Gaulle ça
n'est pas que une France héroïque c'est
une France plus complexe et on envoie en
couverture du point lobby juif et qu'on
sait que c'est un mot de Mitterrand vous
pensez pas que ça peut c'est pas c'est
pas un mot réveiller ou accélérer
l'antisémitisme
est une chose trop sérieuse pour qu'on
puisse traiter à Tori à travers les gens
d'antisémite et c'est pas le cas de
mitter il y a eu une brouille entre
Mitterrand et les responsables de la
communauté juive à un moment donné sur
une question précise sur avec certains
responsables il faut le dire faut pas
écrire une histoire faite de langue de
bois
elle est très complexe on allume et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu